now it just wasn't very good
even after knight p5 i could could do
something
sensible like take on c4 and i was still
doing pretty well but
it was not to be and i gotta say well
done
by by him he was he was spotting
he was spotting some serious tactics
there
[Music]
certainly more than i was
this one
here i don't know
oh this is a way to play
what do i know about this this is weird
okay i don't think it's great but the
fiancee can
never be like too bad
we are getting we are getting some
like english reversed well i mean the
english
reverse is the sicilian reverse but
one of those lines where you go
where you go for bishop c5 and so on
okay i guess i'll do this
like you often go 92 with white so
why not do it as black
okay let's develop this should be seven
possibly rook c8
95 at some point
and
i think he's a little bit better
like even though queen on e3 is a little
bit funny
generally generally the space is nice
like you would love to i've had the pawn
on c4 i think but
still still this is
generally a slightly better position for
white but
still there there aren't any particular
weaknesses
in my camp it's
it has the feeling of something
something quite playable
his last few months are a little bit
weird to me
i guess bringing the bishop around makes
some sense but
pretty happy with the way that i get to
deploy my pieces
and it looks like
obviously it's a bit innocuous
but it also looks very harmonious so i'm
pretty happy
bishop b3 i'm going 95 i think
maybe i should have gone 95 immediately
perhaps that was a lot clever more or
more clever
yeah cleverer is not to worry
uh 94
okay somewhat missed 94.
i think a6b5 is logical trying to gain
some space
and also setting up the famous hedgehog
structure could have been c for speaking
of hedgehogs but
looks like i'm just way up
in terms of the time of what what you
usually have in the anchor
you know what i'm gonna go h5 possibly
bishop h6 at the later point although i
have to watch out for
some knight g6 stuff then or king h7 but
there's knight h5 then
it felt reasonable to gain some space
there
and his pieces look a little bit
uncoordinated
so i'm happy to make
like a half aggressive waiting move
not thrilled about it though
no actually i'm not at all thrilled
about this oh s3 that is a
serious weakening
don't understand the point of that at
all
because
i mean i guess he's protecting e4 but
me don't like the look of it
okay let's go h4 well i can gaining some
space
taking some squares i'm pretty sure he
wanted to go
h4 there and then and then knight h3
okay let's go bishop page six
or is there 96
ugh i don't have time for that okay i'm
gonna
panic and do something else instead
okay i'll take the bishop this probably
wasn't very good
anyway i want ed5 and then either knight
c6 or 96
i got quite a few squares so i'm not
that worried about the use of lonnie
b4 i just keep missing stuff
so annoying okay go 97 back but now i
really wanted that line to go to e6
okay 97 done i guess to protect
okay i'm cleaning
i'm getting out of place
i don't know exactly how badly i'm
playing but i'm certainly playing worse
than he is at the moment
okay we take it then take b4
rook c2 try and get some play
96.
okay queen e5
and we're obviously trying to make a
draw smile
okay now might be a little bit better
okay we got rook before
don't take the pawn yet try and play for
some tricks
first
e3 okay we go back
okay we're definitely playing for tricks
here
definitely playing for tracks
oh that's checkmate
[Music]
so bad just so bad
that was that was like a self-made right
there
oh boy this is gonna be um
it's gonna be a rough day